and you might say well of course you
know what's that that underestimates the
degree to which there's systemic
oppression etc etc and and the and the
vagaries of fate it's like it doesn't
over underestimate it it's not the point
the point is your best strategic
position is how am i insufficient and
how can I rectify that that's what
you've got and the thing is you are
insufficient and you could rectify it
both of those are within your grasp if
you aim low enough one of the things why
do you see the that's another thing you
keep saying aim low enough have a low
enough bar why do you why do you mean
that well let's say you've got a kid and
you want the kid to improve you don't
set them a bar that's so high that it's
impossible for them to attain it you
take a look at the kid and you think
okay this kid's got this range of skill
here's a challenge we can throw at him
or her that exceeds their current level
of skill but gives them a reasonable
probability of success and so like I'm
saying it tongue-in-cheek to some degree
you know it's like but if you're but I'm
doing it as an aid to humility it's like
well I don't know how to start improving
my life someone might say that and I
would say well you're not aiming low
enough there's something you could do
that you are regarding is trivial that
that you could do that you would do that
would result in an actual improvement
but it's not a big enough improvement
for you so you won't lower yourself
enough to take the opportunity
incremental steps yes and so this is
also what is achieved through exercise
it's one of the most important well what
do you do when you go and lift weights
you know going like if you haven't been
stressed before you don't put 400 pounds
on the damn bar and drop the and drop
the bar through your skull right I know
you think look when I started working
out when I was a kid I was I was weighed
about 130 pounds and I was 6 foot 1 it's
a thin kid and I smoked a lot I wasn't
in good shape I wasn't in good physical
shape and I went to the gym and it was
bloody embarrassing you know people
would come over and help me with the
goddamn weights here's how you're
supposed to use this you know it was
humiliating and maybe I was pressing 65
pounds or something at that point you
know but what am I gonna do I'm gonna
lift up 150 pounds and injure myself
right off the bat no I had to go in
there and strip down and put my skinny
goddamn self in front of the mirror and
think son-of-a-bitch there's all these
monsters in the gym who've been lifting
weights for 10 years
and I'm struggling to get 50 pounds off
the bar tough luck for me but I could
lift 50 pounds and it wasn't fair very
long until I could lift 75 and well you
know how it goes but and I never injured
myself when I was late lifting and the
reason for that was I never pushed
myself past where I knew I could go and
I pushed myself a lot you know I gained
35 pounds of muscle in about 3 years in
University I kind of had to quit because
I was eating so god damn much I couldn't
stand it
seeming like six meals a day it was just
taking up too much time but there's a
humility in determining what it is that
the wretched creature that you are can
actually manage aim low and I don't mean
don't aim and I don't mean don't aim up
but you have to accept the fact that you
can set yourself a goal that you can
attain and there's not going to be much
glory in it to begin with because if
you're not in very good shape the goal
that you could a could attain tomorrow
isn't very glorious but it's a hell of a
lot better than nothing and it beats the
hell out of bitterness and it's way
better than blaming someone else it's
way less dangerous and you could do it
and what's cool about it there's a
statement in the New Testament that's
called the Matthew principle an
economist use it to describe how the
economy in the world works to those who
have everything more will be given from
those who have nothing everything will
be taken it's like what's very
pessimistic in some sense because it
means that as you start to fail you fail
more and more rapidly but it also means
that as you start to succeed you succeed
more and more rapidly and so you take an
incremental step and well now you can
lift 55 pounds instead of 52 point 5
pounds you think well what the hell is
that it's like it's one step on a very
long journey and so it's it and it
starts to compound on you so a small
step today means puts you in a position
to take a slightly bigger step to the
next day and then that puts you in a
position to take a slightly bigger step
the next day and you do that for two or
three years man you're starting to
stride